in the light of day the scale of the
devastation becomes clearer
this is the ukrainian city of sumi
in the aftermath of an overnight russian
airstrike
for people here fear has been ever
present
they now potentially
have some hope
a temporary ceasefire between moscow and
kiev that's led to the creation of this
humanitarian corridor
for his part ukrainian president
vladimir zelinski condemned the repeated
violation of ceasefire deals with russia
while adding civilians urgently need to
be evacuated from besieged cities
the occupants want our people to die we
have sent columns of caravans of
humanitarian aid to mariappol they are
brave people and they understand that
the russian military can destroy this
convoy on its way
the number of people fleeing russia's
advance has now reached 2 million
that's according to the u.n refugee
agency
as the humanitarian impact of the war
worsens the un's high commissioner for
human rights says everyone escaping
violence should be allowed safe passage
i'm deeply concerned about civilians
trapped in active hostilities in
numerous areas and i urge all parties to
take effective action to enable all
civilians including those in situational
vulnerability to safely leave areas
affected by conflict
the questions now
how long will the fighting stop
and how many people will be able to get
to safety
al jazeera
so